el agua ha sido durante mucho tiempo un
lujo aquí en estos suburbios de las
afueras de Caracas algunos hacen viajes
diarios a la ladera para extraer agua de
tuberías rotas yo ni cuello pasa horas
conduciendo en busca de agua que cada
dos semanas para tomar y para la casa
que hace cada diario tengo que llevar
porque
puede ser una vez a la semana y por dos
horas hora y media cuando llega y el
resto no no tenemos a nada de agua
Carmen Urías dice que su comunidad ha
vivido más de dos décadas sin agua
corriente en sus casas obligada a
comprar contenedores a comer samples
informales aquí tenemos demasiados con
el agua tenemos que comprar estos
pipotes ya dos dólares y a dos dólares y
medio que no no traen el agua de allá
que no lo venden más económica y tenemos
más de 20 años que nosotros no sabemos
lo que es un agua de tubería la empresa
Estatal encargada de suministrar agua a
los venezolanos no tiene capacidad para
hacerlo en medio del colapso económico
del país y los fallos de las
infraestructuras así como el aumento de
las temperaturas y la disminución de las
precipitaciones Mientras tanto la
inflación sigue presionando a la baja el
valor de los salarios de la gente al
tiempo que hace subir los precios al
consumidor